dear Minister hoekstrom a dear members
of parliament dear ambassadors and
journalists dear representatives of
international organizations political
and judicial communities dear people
first of all people people of the
Netherlands and I'm glad to be in your
strong country now
now the land of freedom and Justice
which are Universal values and it is
about these things that I will speak
today of course of course we all want to
see different
Vladimir
here
in The Hague
the one who deserves to be
sentenced for these criminal actions
right here in the capital of the
international law
and I'm sure we will see that happen
when we win and we will win
and when we will not just on the
battlefield not just against this
aggression look at how countries around
the world are coming together to help
ukrainians
defend themselves
what is at the heart of this desire to
help
the feeling that more than the faith of
one country is at stake the feeling that
more can be achieved than the defeat of
one aggressor
we can now stop Wars of aggression as
such we can defeat aggression as a
criminal idea that
originates in the mindset of someone who
is used to impunity
immunity is the key that opens the door
to aggression
if you look at any War any any war of
aggression in the history and they all
have one thing in common
the perpetrators of the world didn't
believe they would have to stand to
answer for what they did
they must tend to answer for war
however brings war must receive judgment
ladies and gentlemen
defeating impunity of aggressors means
destroying the origins of aggression
victory in the war is won by Force of
Arms
that's how how their job gets done
and I'm grateful to you to you and the
Netherlands for every piece of weapon
supplied to Ukraine for everything that
helps us to maintain our defense and
gradually prepare our active actions
but we know that the lasting peace after
Victory is achieved by nothing else but
the strengths of values towards the wall
it's the strength of freedom
and of law
which must work to the full of Ensure
Justice
not hybrid promises
instead of Human Rights
real freedom
not hybrid impunity and symbolic
formalities but full scale Justice not
hybrid peace and constant flashes of
violence on the front line but reliable
peace when one respects values true
Freedom True Justice through peace is
respected instead of hybrid forms but
it's exactly what we need now